what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and today we have some news about the
Fantastic Four we'll be talking about
some of the plot in this video as well
as what an executive producer of Marvel
Studios has said about the movie but
we're also going to be talking about
some casting news some casting news that
is probably going to upset some fans not
all but some fans in regards to Marvel
studios's casting choices in fact I have
already seen many many people online and
I've seen it for a while people
complaining about this possibility now
the first thing that is going to
probably upset people myself included is
the report that John Krasinski is not
going to be playing Reed Richards this
comes from The Insider my time to shine
hello if you've been following the
channel you have definitely heard that
name she has recently tweeted out that
John Krasinski is not the MCU read
Richards now I'm disappointed in this
because I think that he just made a
perfect read Richards he looked exactly
like him in Multiverse of Madness and I
think John Krasinski is a great overall
actor so I was really excited at the
possibility that he was going to be the
main mcu's Reed Richards unfortunately
according to my time to shine hello he
won't be and she has a very good track
record when it comes to Scoops so this
is most likely true so that's one thing
and that's just the small thing I know
this other one is going to ruffle a
little feathers but first thank you to
betterhelp for sponsoring this video
look no matter who you are life can be
hard it's hard for everyone including
myself which is why I found better help
to be extremely useful and very
convenient betterhelp is the world's
largest therapy service and it's 100
online with better help you can tap into
a network of over 25 000 licensed and
experienced therapists who can help you
with a wide range of issues all you have
to do to get started is answer a few
questions about your needs and
preferences in therapy that way better
help can better match you with a
therapist that suits your needs then
from there you can call you can text you
can chat or you can voice call with your
your therapist you can message your
therapist at any time and schedule live
sessions when it's convenient for you
and one of the great things about it is
if your therapist isn't the right fit
for you for any reason you can switch to
new therapist at no additional charge
the best thing about betterhelp is you
get the same professionalism and quality
you expect from in office therapy but
with the therapist who is custom picked
for you more scheduling flexibility and
at a more affordable price so get 10 off
your first month at betterhelp.com
Cosmic Wonder that's betterhelp
help.com Cosmic Wonder or you can click
the link in description down below okay
so the second one is not only coming
from previous reports but something that
a recent executive producer Nate Moore
has said in a recent interview here is
what he recently said about the
Fantastic Four in an interview with
deadline uh Fantastic Four Fantastic
Four we have Matt shackman directing
who's so talented and who did one
division for us
and I think people are going to be
pretty surprised about what we're doing
now that first part is pretty
self-explanatory way this is something
that we already knew Matt shackman is
going to be directing the Fantastic Four
film I am personally excited for this
because he directed One Division and one
division so far is my second favorite
MCU Disney Plus show right after Loki
nothing has managed to take the Loki
Reigns yet it is still number one for me
but one division is so close I think
Matt checkman did an excellent job with
it but that second part this is what has
some people up in arms because although
this could mean many different things
many people are talking online right now
how this could mean that the cast is
going to be very diverse and this
actually falls into previous reports one
coming from Grace Randolph that Marvel
Studios is looking to cast a person of
color as Reed Richards now again I have
seen this all online recently some
people love this idea some people don't
really care but some people hate this
there's been a lot of talk and
speculation recently that Reed Richards
and the MCU could be played by a black
actor now of course I've heard people
say they don't want this but here's
something that's pretty interesting
about this there is a little bit of a
president right now for this to actually
happen in the MCU for Reed Richards to
be black I think they could possibly be
setting this up already with Kang the
Conqueror why because Jonathan Majors
who of course plays King the Conqueror
is black now some of you may know where
I'm going with this if you're a comic
book fan or if you've been following my
videos about King you probably know that
it matters because Kang is believed to
be a descendant of Reed Richards in the
comics Reed Richards is Kang's great
great great great great on and on and on
grandpa or uncle or whatever they don't
really specify all they really tell us
is that he is the relative of Reed
richards's half-brother at least to my
knowledge that is all they've told us
the important part is they are related
in fact Kang's real name is Nathaniel
Richards and guess what read richards's
father's name is you guessed it it is
Nathaniel Richards so if they are going
to go with in the MCU the story that
Nathaniel Richards AKA King the
Conqueror and Reed Richards aka Mr
Fantastic are related then like I said
there is sort of a president right now
in the MCU for Reed Richards to be
played by a black actor now of course
obviously you can have distant relatives
and ancestors that are a completely
different race than you because people
marry different people and different
races every day they have babies and
they're mixed and that continues through
generations obviously so Reed Richards
does not have to be black but I do think
the story of Reed and Kang being related
is something that they should dive into
in the MCU especially since we know that
Reed is going to play a key role in
secret Wars in defeating Kang in fact we
already have seen the connections
between them primarily one huge
connection that we do believe is going
to play a role in secret Wars and that
is their Tech and Doctor Strange and the
Multiverse of Madness we got a glimpse
of Reed richards's the smartest man
Alive's Tech we saw him teleport into
the Illuminati room using technology you
opened up a blue portal and appeared out
of nowhere here's the thing we saw this
again in the post-credit scene for
Ant-Man and the wasp quantumania and if
you have not seen it here is your
official spoiler alert just plug your
ears and close your eyes for the next 30
seconds or so in the mid credit scene
Ford Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania we
saw the Council of Kang's call every
variant of Kang or so they said and we
saw these variants appearing in the same
exact portal teleportation device that
read Richards used in Multiverse of
Madness they are literally exactly the
same and we know how Marvel is with the
MCU we know how Kevin feige is
everything is connected everything is
connected for a big reason and this
reason I believe is definitely going to
come into play in the MCU King hates the
Fantastic Four they're the first team
that ever foiled his plans all the way
back in ancient Egypt the first place
that he ever time traveled to so I'm
very much looking forward to their
Connection in the MCU now of course
there is always the possibility that
Nate Moore was not talking about the
cast he could have been talking about
the story or he could have been talking
about both but as far as the story is
concerned we do know a little bit about
what the story is going to be about no
insane details yet but some good ones to
start off with for starters Marvel
Studios is President Kevin feige said
that this is not going to be a true
origin story the MCU has kind of been
known to do that if a story has already
been told multiple times then Kevin
feige typically wants to steer clear
from it this is why they said they
didn't do the origin story of Spider-Man
that we're used to seeing with Uncle Ben
Dyne because we've all seen it before
doesn't make it right but that's their
reasoning and I do understand so perhaps
the same thing applies for the Fantastic
Four's origin here we've already seen it
a few times on film so not an origin
story but we also know according to a
report from Insider Jeff Snyder that
Reed Richards and Sue storm are going to
be parents in the film now I personally
am really excited for this storyline
because in the comics read and see to
have two kids Valeria and Franklin and
Franklin Richards is one of if not the
most powerful mutant and Omega Level
mutant to ever exist in Marvel history
he literally at one point used Galactus
as a puppet controlling him he has the
power to create pocket little universes
and at one point in time in the comics
he even used his powers to age himself
into an adult so needless to say I am
very excited to possibly see Franklin
Richards in the MCU and if this report
is true we are going to see him even if
he's just a baby in the MCU very very
soon but let me know what you think
about all of this news in the comments
down below how do you feel about it do
you think it'll work or not let us know
Down Below in the comments don't forget
to like the video and subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest
Fantastic Four News don't forget to
follow us on Instagram and Twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching wolf wolf
foreign